what you do today um may or may not pay
off right away I think the best way to
make sure that you're um I guess uh you
know on the right path is to look at the
inputs um because the outcomes may not
always be there every month or every
week um and and so you know at door Das
um you know for us it's always been
about improving the selection that we
offer customers the quality of the
delivery in terms of our timeliness and
our speed um and our accuracy as well as
the affordability of the service um you
know that's what we were focused on we
weren't looking necessarily at outcome
metrics per se we were looking a lot at
the input metrics and um and and that
maniacal focus on that was the bet that
we made um that ultimately would
translate into things that maybe others
might appreciate or care about um
because at some point you do have to you
know show your cards so to speak and um
make sure that maybe some of the ideas
you had would translate into Real
Results um and for us I think we always
understood that you know relationship
between what we were working on and what
the outcomes would be maybe they
wouldn't happen in the same time period
that we were working on improving the
inputs but I think having that
understanding and then having the um
patience if you will uh to keep working
the inputs um and then letting the score
take care of itself I think those are
things that we both had to solve